they won't fear it until they understand
it
and they won't understand it
until they've used it
oftenham's story is one of the biggest
stories imaginable
our film tries to take you into his
experience and IMAX for me is a portal
into a level of immersion that you can't
get from other formats IMAX is a format
of spectacle and it's made for Vistas
and for the Grandeur of it but I got
very curious to discover this as an
intimate format the face is like a
landscape there's a huge complexity and
a huge depth to it how can we get this
camera closer to people how can we get
this medium to work also as a very
intimate medium
always pushing the boundaries and
innovating with each film he does on
this one one of the things that was
really important in the script was the
juxtaposition of color in black and
white
I don't think Chris would be capable of
doing something kind of the way everyone
else does it he kind of invented this
idea of shooting an IMAX for feature
film and so you're kind of on The
Cutting Edge of this stuff every time
you work with him how are we going to do
it because 65 millimeter black and white
was a format that didn't exist so there
was a lot of engineering that went into
that we actually had to create the black
and white film that we were using to
shoot we were able to test large format
black and white put it up on a giant
iMac screen and have a look at it and
and the results were just magical and
inspiring
I was sitting in the back of a 47
Packard with an IMAX mag on my lap
trying to get this driving shot and I
just felt like I went back to some
origins of great Cinema School
because you know these lenses are coming
at you and they're this close and it
wakes you up we've shot with IMAX many
times on other movies but watching the
very different sort of film on that big
screen it sort of makes you gasp you'll
write in their experience I think it
feels quite human it feels like you are
in that moment with them you know it's a
Mythic massive story this is an
unforgettable unmissable experience in a
theater
Chris makes films for theaters for movie
going audiences and the best the most
immersive version of that is IMAX it
gets thrown up on a gigantic screen and
the moment you watch it it's very
evident the quality is unprecedented
15th of iMac 70 mil is the highest
quality Imaging format that's ever been
devised it allows you to fully immerse
yourself in the story where the
audiences will see the solar IMAX on the
big screen there will be
experience an extraordinary moment in
human history
foreign foreign